Space Shuttle Atlantis is the only shuttle on display in the world...
...with its payload doors open, just like on its many missions,...
...complete with a full-scale replica of the Hubble Space Telescope...
...and a chance to learn about the shuttle program's 30-year history...
...from a vantage point like no other.
Train in the astronaut training simulator area,...
...featuring 21 consoles and interactive experiences...
...that allow you to not only practice landing a space shuttle,...
...but also take the controls and dock with the International Space Station.
Once you've seen Space Shuttle Atlantis up close and completed your training,...
...you'll be inspired and ready for the shuttle launch experience.
Get ready to take the ride of your life...
...and learn what it's like to launch in the shuttle.
Climb on board and feel the rumble and shake...
...as you go vertical and experience the feeling of what astronauts went through...
...as they accelerated to 17,500 miles an hour...
...on their eight-and-a-half-minute rocket ride to orbit.
A veteran space shuttle commander guides you through the launch sequence...
...and prepares you for this high-definition, audio-visual simulation that is like no other.